es ist soweit endlich weit uns ihnen
masken seine pläne ein
in das vielleicht ehrgeizigste ziel dass
ein mensch selbst eine firma jemals
hatte den mars zu besiedeln
nicht nur den mars zu erreichen oder
menschen auf den mars zu bringen sondern
den roten planeten lebensfähig zu machen
und eine gesellschaft aufzubauen die
dort unabhängig von der erde überleben
kann
um das zu erreichen baut spacex
gigantische raketen entwickelt
revolutionäre methoden und braucht
astronomische viel geld
eine million menschen das ist das ziel
ab einer million menschen die dauerhaft
auf dem mars leben ist die gesellschaft
laut imas autonom und nicht mehr von der
erde abhängig die letzte kalkulation der
nasa für die kosten einer mars-mission
betrug 50 milliarden dollar für eine
fünf mann crew
das sind 10 milliarden dollar pro person
eine million menschen für jeweils zehn
milliarden dollar zum mars zu fliegen
ist offensichtlich keine option
deswegen hat ihre maske ein ehrgeiziges
ziel er will die menschen für ihre reise
zum mars selber zahlen lassen und um das
zu erreichen müssen zwei dinge passieren
menschen müssen auf dem mars leben
wollen und die kosten für eine mars
reise müssen drastisch sinken so weit
dass man sich die reise als
normalsterblicher leisten kann dass
menschen auf dem mars leben wollen
wissen wir spätestens seit der
umstrittenen kampagne über 200.000
bewerber für einen flug ohne rückreise
zum mars erhalten hat preis nicht
versucht ihre maske die reise zum mars
für den wert eines einfamilienhauses zu
verkaufen das sind zu beginn 500.000
dollar später auch nur 200.000 oder
sogar 900.000 dollar pro person
das ist ein hunderttausendstel der
aktuellen kosten
das ist so als würde man sagen ein tesla
kostet aktuell hunderttausend euro
wir versuchen den preis jetzt auf einen
euro runter zu drücken damit leute sich
dieses auto auch wirklich kaufen wollen
das wird natürlich leider niemals
passieren also wie viele maske die mars
reise für so wenig geld anbieten können
zum eigenen durch wiederverwendbare
raketen spacex arbeitet schon seit
jahren daran ihre raketen wieder sicher
auf der erde landen zu lassen anstatt
sie einfach ins meer fallen zu lassen
wie es bisher in der raumfahrtindustrie
üblich war
spacex wird immer besser und sicherer in
diesen landungen und kann somit die
kosten für komplett neue raketen bei
jedem einzelnen staat streichen und muss
nur noch für kraftstoff und
sicherheitschecks bezahlen
stellt euch vor wir würden unsere
flugzeuge nach jedem flug verschrotten
und immer mit fabrikneuen flugzeugen
fliegen ein ticket von berlin nach new
york würde 15 millionen euro kosten
das wiederverwenden von raketen alleine
kann die kosten für weltraum reisen um
das 100 vielleicht sogar das
tausendfache verringern
ein weiterer riesiger faktor ist die
größe 26 will nicht fünf sondern
mindestens 100 menschen gleichzeitig zum
mars bringen und dafür braucht man
natürlich die entsprechende rakete darf
ich vorstellen
der mars kolonien transporter oder das
interplanetary transportsystem space
access sich mit dem namen noch nicht so
ganz sicher aber das ist auch egal denn
diese rakete ist riesig mit 120 metern
höhe wird sie die größte rakete sein die
die menschheit je gebaut hat
größer als die saturn 5 und das mit drei
mal soviel schubkraft ganz genau dreimal
so viel
diese rakete ist ein wolkenkratzer und
das muss sie auch sein denn je größer
die rakete ist desto effizienter wird
sie auch und desto kostengünstiger wird
es menschen und güter ins all zu bringen
bis zu 450 tonnen material und bis zu
300 menschen soll der msc transportieren
können um dieses unglaubliche gewicht
heben zu können hat spacex einen neuen
booster erfunden den raptor booster ein
raptor hat einen durchmesser von nur
zwei metern kann aber 310 tonnen schub
generieren genug um eine boeing 747 in
die luft zu heben und der mars kolonien
transporter hat 42 dieser raptor booster
das sind 13.000 tonnen schub genug um
7.000 autos zu heben
das hier sind aufnahmen vom test eines
raptor boosters anders als die
vorherigen booster von spacex laufen die
raptor wusste übrigens auch methan mehr
dazu später
ok also wie sieht so eine mars mission
von spacex wirklich aus alle 26 monate
öffnet sich ein zeitfenster in dem ich
besonders effizient ist zum mars zu
fliegen weil uns ja maß in dieser zeit
am nächsten ist zu jedem anderen
zeitpunkt dazwischen kostet es
wesentlich mehr treibstoff den roten
planeten zu erreichen wenn dieses
zeitfenster erreicht es bringt der mars
colonial transporter eine kapsel mit 100
bis 200 menschen in den orbit der erde
dort separiert sich die rakete von der
kapsel
komm zurück zur erde um dort zu landen
und direkt eine weitere kapsel in die
umlaufbahn zu bringen
dieses mal allerdings nicht mit menschen
sondern mit treibstoff an bord
die treibstoff kapsel fühlt dann den
tank der reise kapsel im orbit auf das
ist eine neuartige methode mit der space
ex die kosten für die reise erneut um
das fünf bis zehnfache verringern will
dieser vorgang muss laut thiele musk
drei bis fünfmal wiederholt werden bis
der tank komplett gefüllt ist und die
kapsel mit den menschen zum mars
aufbrechen kann
fun fact die reise kapsel ist mit neuen
laptop ostern ausgestattet und hat damit
mehr schubkraft als richtige raketen die
von der erde aus starten
sie sind nur darum schnell zum mars zu
kommen und ihre maske will schnell zum
mars die meisten experten rechnen mit 6
bis 9 monatigen reisen zum mars macht
will das in drei monaten schaffen
genau hier auf der erde wird die kapsel
auf dem mars senkrecht landen
die atmosphäre auf dem mars ist
wesentlich dünner als unsere auf der
erde was die landung per fallschirm
erschwert außerdem soll die reise kapsel
wieder verwendet werden denn sie startet
bald und macht sich auf den weg zurück
zur erde und den treibstoff dafür den
gibt es auf dem mars
das ist der grund dafür dass die raptor
booster auf methan basis funktionieren
denn mit hilfe von kohlenstoffdioxid und
gefrorenem wasser auf dem mars kann man
diesen treibstoff vor ort herstellen
anstatt ihnen den ganzen weg von der
erde mitzubringen eine weitere riesige
kostenreduktion 100.000 flüge so viel
braucht sex um eine million menschen auf
den mars zu bringen
telemaxx vision ist es dass alle 26
monate bis zu 1000 raketen gleichzeitig
zum mars fliegen und wir ihn vielleicht
40 bis 100 jahren eine million menschen
auf dem mars haben mit dem tank füllen
den raketen sind das 3000 raketen starts
alle 26 monate
das ist das 15 fache der aktuellen
weltweiten rate und spätestens hier
sollten immer darüber sprechen wie
realitätsnah das alles ist
spacex hat noch nie einen einzigen
menschen ins weltall gebracht
noch im september ist eine rakete auf
der startplattform explodiert diese
dinge passieren regelmäßig und trotzdem
will spacex 2024 die ersten menschen zum
mars schicken das ist in acht jahren 15
jahre vor der erwarteten bemannten mars
mission der nasa und macht verschweigt
weiterhin eine menge probleme auf der
reise zum mars und auf dem mars selber
sind menschen viel schlechter vor
kosmischer strahlung geschützt
als unter unserer erdatmosphäre es
herrscht also erhöhtes krebsrisiko
und das größte problem von allen könnte
die mikrogravitation seien auf dem mars
wird nur ein drittel der schwerkraft das
kann auf dauer zu muskelschwund und
problem mit der augenmuskulatur führen
und ist auch der grund warum astronauten
auf der iss
täglich eine menge sport machen müssen
viele macht selber sagt bist du bereit
zu sterben wenn ja dann bist du ein
kandidat für diese reise und selbst wenn
all diese fragen geklärt sind vielen
space sex immer noch riesige mengen geld
die sie so schnell nicht durch die isaf
mission für die nase verdienen können
und optikstadt die richtige plattform
ist um die erste extra touristische
gesellschaft aufzubauen ist auch
fraglich aber ultimativ brauchen wir
leute wie ihre maske träumer als er mit
dem verkauf von paypal 165 millionen
dollar gemacht hat und als nächstes die
auto industrie revolutionieren wollte
hat auch jeder gedacht dass er verrückt
war inzwischen spiel tesla motors nicht
nur an der spitze der elektrischen autos
mit sondern auch an der spitze der
selbstfahrenden autos wie viele macht
selber gesagt hat technischer
fortschritt passiert nicht von allein
es arbeiten jeden tag hunderttausende
genialer ingenieure und programmierer
damit wie die ss das neueste smartphone
vier kameras oder vier kameras in
smartphones haben jeder schritt in
richtung mars bringt den roten planeten
als neues zuhause näher und wir werden
sehen wohin uns diese reise führt 2018
will spacex bereits die erste beladen
rakete zum mars schicken
spätestens dann werden wir sehen wie vor
bereitet das unternehmen wirklich ist
und wie viele noch passieren muss bis
der erste mensch einen fuß auf den mars
setzt